[音楽]
おはようございますなぁビッド j
あっあーっ
おったん
ん
やばいよございました18町ですついに買っちまいましたあの北
4を
この日美骨で者僕
きな音出るもの大好きなんですよね今までいろんな大きな音出るものを使っていたん
ですけどもやっぱり僕の心唯一ガッツリ掴んだのはこの子だけでしたもう一度だっけ
なぁとブサヨ年前にこれを使って人ををしたことがあるんですけども
もう本当に面白かったですうん普通の大きかったじゃないんですよね
なんかこう中でぇー音が体に響きわたるというか本人の間住めると脊髄が揺れたと言っ
ておりましたためにあのドラって高いんですよ h 21年だけでも4万円しました
から僕が行万円前もらう価値があるかい
有効な使い方が出来たかな
思いましてもっとやりたいもっともっといろんな人の身体を揺らしてあげたいそう思っ
た瞬間には
買ってましたっていうこちらの本物の中華ドラお値段の桜なんと30万ギョン
1000円でございます
上の子のドランスタンド合わせるともう約40万円ぐらいですかね
逆にいます御10回レンタルするより1回ちょっと方がもっと使えるのでお得なんで
すごくやってること新品な飲み屋パトラってもすでに作ってるから出ちゃうんですね
こんな感じです新品です開いたけどもう買っちゃったんでもう無限にできるわけですよ
無限に人の体を震えさせることができるこんな幸せなことはない人だけどちょっとあー
サイズなんですけど
早速
本場の空を使って人を起こしていきましょう
を把握もよ
やばいやばい
[音楽]
ame
me
wh
バッハ
あああああっ入ったよマジで
[笑い]
[音楽]
me
uh
うううう
me
re だった
やばいポッドで人間パシフィックリス覚えてないですよ
してやるあーー
ああああああああうんはーいいっ
虫 vita やヴァイスは知っどどうでしたからさ
声で売ってるだろねむーい